[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's rich eisen the host of the nfl
network the rich eisen show on peacock
that follows ours and he joins us on the
program how's morale rich morale's great
dan um you know not to pull back the
curtain and peel back the layers but
you sat down like 10 seconds before the
segment began that was a very
burman-like move
out of you dan uh normally you're in
place you're in position best i can
recall from back in the day i mean you
sat down headphone on you did the read
yeah thought you were talking about my
family being extraordinary but you were
talking about mercedes-benz which i
understand it's your sponsor yeah um you
know but that's my observations to kick
off this conversation i would always cut
it close on sportscenter because it was
such a long walk from the newsroom
all the way over
and inevitably you'd run into somebody
or somebody would hand you something and
i'd sit down now i never got to the
point where the music was playing with
the sportscenter theme but i i cut it
closer than i needed to so i still have
nightmares
about showing up late
for sportscenter i have them too uh one
of the first times i i almost was late
uh was in the very very very beginning
back in 96 when i come down the stairs
from the third floor where you had an
office
and i had a cubicle um and i come down
the stairs to walk to the second floor
hallway that gets to the studio and
that's where i first met craig kilbourne
who
asked me if i was the new guy that was
on the air and i'm like yeah i was he
goes that's right you're doing a lot of
my stuff
and then we
we walked the other way uh that's the
way i got introduced to the the great
craig kilbourne killer kilby lord kilby
himself yeah did it get any better your
relationship with killborn since he
accused you of basically plagiarizing it
did it went up from there like a rocket
[ __ ] dan i had him on this show just
last month so uh you know he's still
kill b he's got a pod now
he's got his pod now and uh he's doing
great so yeah we're good well i saw
where keith oberman has a podcast now
craig kilbourne has a podcast now
yeah
and it's the worst thing you can hear
hey
i've got a podcast
would you be a guest
well but the answer is yeah i mean i
know but
like you would do it but
i had somebody say hey i got a podcast
and uh i'm only going to keep you for 20
minutes
and so i go over and and basically i'm
sort of in a closet and and
we went an hour i had to interrupt the
person doing a podcast to say
hey
i gotta go
and it goes oh i thought we were having
a great time yeah
like i didn't want to be mean or rude
but after 20 minutes we got to 60
minutes and i had to say i gotta go
it's when the host overstays his or her
invitation i don't know what it is but
you can tell you know obviously dan you
having
done uh your show um since the beginning
of time
essentially uh at espn you can tell when
you're interviewing somebody that you've
gone a little bit longer than they
expected their answers get a little bit
shorter and clippy right i mean you can
i can say i can feel it you know it took
me a few years to figure that one out
but i can sense it now and sometimes
when you're in in front of somebody you
can tell i mean it's easier they have a
tell like um kind of done with this but
but then when it's on radio or podcast
you have to listen for that and i did an
interview with david harbour from
stranger things hopper
and he was unbelievable
and then he got to a point where it was
around 28 minutes
and the answers got shorter
and then i realized
okay i gotta i gotta wrap this up so i i
think i asked one or two more questions
and then that was it but he gave me
the hint because the answers got shorter
it's the hopper line the 28 minute is
the
main proper line when things get
stranger well somebody will go he got a
couple of minutes it's never a couple of
minutes ever
ever ever yeah right
yes i am all right so the commissioner
is on the clock here ah yes
what do you think the commissioner will
and should do
um i think what he's what he should do
is double the suspension
because that i think puts watson and i
would believe the players association in
the
in the uh position of
maybe
suing i don't know if they would sue if
he does the full year
i think they end up trying to place this
into court
and that's where we can see
potentially a restraining order being
put in so watson plays week one
and i don't know if the league
wants that to happen
and i think they
maybe just double the suspension make it
12 games so you know watson can return
this year
um and it also is a significant
suspension more than the six games
obviously six games is a third of the
season but
i'm already seeing players in the league
tweeting about talking about and i'm
hearing what they're saying as well that
six games is essentially a sus a
vacation
for him
um it doesn't bite into his salary
because the way that the browns
um
put his contract together so it it
doesn't go the full year
um where that would potentially i think
that would absolutely trigger a court
case that he'd like to avoid but outside
of all that um
that's what i think he should do because
12 games is significant
what if he doesn't do anything
well i mean not doing anything
would be born out of him
trying to
um
show that this process wasn't if you
will a sham that this is what was
collectively bargained
uh between the players and the judge and
that even it is though it is his right
to jack up the suspension he won't do it
because of the potential criticism that
he will not um
uh take this process seriously and um i
i don't think he's going to do that and
just leave it the way it is that that's
the only reason why he would leave it
the way it is because you saw
in the in the
in the um opinion if you read what the
judge wrote she basically said watson
did it wasn't remorseful about doing it
um but due to the way that things have
happened in the past where the league
has
moved around what the the precedence is
for a suspension because the collect the
uh policy was kind of a mess
with the ray rice issue and that's even
brought up in there and brady with
deflategate that the league has moved
the goalposts if you will on what's
precedence and what's not in the past
and
so i i think
maybe just maybe they're pointing out
how what a mess it used to be to say
that precedence is this now and if the
league leaves that precedence then
they're they're done with the past and
they can reset this policy moving
forward i don't think that's what the
league's going to do
i think they they will up it i heard
what you said in the previous segment
that you're hearing the hammers being
brought down doubling the suspension
might be the the way to kind of
thread the needle
yeah i just don't think you could put
somebody in place and then all of a
sudden say we don't like what your first
ruling is right so now we're going to
bigfoot you here
then the next time this happens we're
like it just kind of sets a bad
precedent and it feels like everything
is precedent here with hey this happened
to zeke elliott this happened to ben
roethlisberger
therefore the judge came to this hey
here's the precedent you had a ruling
and we didn't agree with it now we're
gonna bigfoot you i i don't it just gets
into dangerous territory i don't like
the ruling
i would have suspended him for a year
but i also have to factor in everything
she pointed out
in you know in her summary here i'd like
she was fair to
the sample size of and the history of
everything that's happened here i don't
like it but i blame the nfl for getting
in this position well i mean
ultimately it's desean watson that's put
everybody in this position and um
so
there's the court of public opinion that
matters dan because
everyone seems to forget um that yes
this is a judge who's deciding this and
yes this is a collective bargaining
agreement that has been hammered out
between two sides uh of a business and
that's what this is it is a business
this is not a court of law this wasn't a
grand jury
those are the people that um we should
potentially take a look at down in
houston as to why
if this was defined
per the uh nfl's collective bargaining
agreements definition of sexual assault
then why didn't that meet the bar
legally what's going on there
this is not the judge and jury and the
actual judge and jury this is the nfl
this is a business and the court of
public opinion
matters yeah there are
enough
uh consumers pissed off about this
that i believe the nfl is going to act
we're talking to rich eisen nfl network
host and host of the rich eisen show you
can watch that on peacock following our
show
the nationals are in the process of
calling up multiple minor leaguers
i would believe juan soto is gonzo
and
i'm i'm here in the cardinals
i'm hearing the cardinals but i i don't
have any any verification on that i mean
it could be the padres i don't know but
i'm wondering if uh if
he's going to go to the cardinals but
that's whoever did they better not send
him they've been they better not send
him a commercial ticket right they
should uh they better send it yet they
can get them yeah right yeah because
that's as we all know that's that's the
way you treat juan soto you better send
uh
that
you know you know you don't put them in
first class for the for the home run
derby are you
are you going to be a rams or chargers
guy this year who goes farther
oh the rams
you know this is this is west coast um
you know
or east coast bias against the west
coast dan what if the patriots honestly
take a look at what the rams did last
year all right and what they did in the
off season
and adding alan robinson and adding
bobby wagner and keeping aaron donald in
the fold and their coach in the fold and
cooper cup is getting paid look at how
they have set everything up for their
repeat possibility
championship season and just imagine if
the patriots were the team just remove
the rams and insert patriots in that
spot in certain giants insert cowboys in
that spot the whole country would be
descending upon
rams training camp and trying to figure
out what's going on it's just because
it's los angeles and everybody figured
you know stafford that was a a real nice
story he got a a
you know
a tv commercial out of it you know a
phone commercial a phone deal out of it
honestly they they've set everything up
they've got the coach the quarterback
the wide receiver coming off a triple
crown season cam akers is more healthy
they've got wagner behind um behind
donald in front of ramsey i mean they're
set they're set and and the rest of the
division appears to have gotten weaker
when you assume the niners are going to
start a quarterback that will have even
more ups and downs than jimmy garoppolo
which is saying a lot
so um
i will take the ramps 1000
in that game yeah but we haven't had
repeaters and since the patriots in o3
right first two seasons of nfl network
as a matter of fact those were the last
time that was and we're turning 20 next
year so it's been a while that said um i
i'm not saying they're going to repeat
you asked which one's going to go
further and i need to see what the
chargers look like they have made i'm
sure a charger fan um
would would counter that they got khalil
mack and they had a jc jackson and it's
another year for justin herbert
and i do like what they've done and what
they can be but that division i think is
much tougher than the nfc west and i'll
take the defending champs in that
construct i worry and you know this um
since we work in the business like the
mother ship last week was all win on the
raiders
they had a day and a half where all they
did is talk about the raiders and
so they're the hot team
i always get nervous with that when
somebody's like they're all in
on
on a team and the raiders and then you
know derek carr says hey you know nobody
talks about us i'm done do you watch
espn
well i've been on them since march when
they got devonte adams and then signed
chandler jones
and i called my shot saying that you
know and i've i've talked myself into it
are they too hot though richard
i'm taking on the win the division you
know i'm taking them to win the division
wow
it's so rare to add somebody like
davonte adams and anybody want a piece
of rich eisen pie to the face little pie
no pies no pies i know you're gonna go
in the pie what
what do you mean how about a cake not a
pie
cake to the face
i don't know a baked good might have
more heft to it i i don't i don't know
what you're doing
yeah i think we do a potato knish to the
face
and if they're eliminated by hanukkah it
would be perfect timing right that okay
so no pie to the face so you you're not
i mean it's it's it's a it's a total
dartboard shot here because it's the
toughest division in football all right
what if fritzy takes the broncos
oh that'll take okay
for a kanish to the face
[Laughter]
whatever a canisius
okay well it's it's it's it's like a
potato uh sort of like a potato calzone
is the way i would describe it the goya
mountain yeah
just saying it could it could be pretty
hot okay okay gotta be careful with the
condition okay so fritzy you guys we're
saying the broncos will finish better
than the raiders is that a refrigerated
konish to the face yes to make things
the safest possible yes let's do that
let's do that fair enough that's fun
fair enough absolutely well while the
rest of the dan patrick and rich eisen
show staff do the horror around us
lift us on a chair oh yeah yeah yeah you
know you know that happens now where
it's not a jewish wedding
really i went to two weddings this
summer
and they're sampling because all of a
sudden somebody's up on a chair and i go
wait is he jewish and then they go no
and i go
wait a minute it's not cool you can't
sample traditions like that that's like
the seinfeld episode where uh you know
uh tim watley the dentist
he he became a jew just so he could tell
jewish jokes i mean that's not
that's not cool like you can't just take
the the chair and and the whole road
taking that you got to take the guilt
with it
i was going to step in
on behalf of my jewish brethren
and i was going to say hey
get down from there come on yes yes you
have by the way i give you full rights
to do that the hood spa
of these meshugganas
and i said what are we doing
yes
dan well done thank you welcome thank
you well thank you rich good to talk to
you buddy always take care that's rich
eisen the popular host of the nfl
network and the rich eisen show that
follows you're being serious about this
wedding thing two weddings this summer
both
had the lift the chair you know put the
bride in the
groom up there on the chairs